everything in the real world is being
recreated in the virtual world the
metaverse
the metaverse a persistent digital
universe that mirrors our world
but is becoming as diverse and
awe-inspiring as the natural world
and you'll be able to do everything you
do in the real world in the virtual
world and more in the real world you can
walk into a gallery by a one-of-a-kind
artwork that is signed and authenticated
as original take it home
put it on the wall enjoy it show it to
your friends
it might even be an investment
the artwork becomes part of your story
and adds meaning to your life
it marks a time and a feeling for you
now we can have the exact same
experience in virtual galleries with
digital art
while this might seem like an obscure
niche on the internet
let's take a look at a recent auction
sale that you might have heard of
in march of 2021 the major auction house
christie's sold a purely digital artwork
by an artist named beeple for 69 million
dollars in cryptocurrency
the auction the artwork
and the currency was virtual
but the transaction was very real but
who can afford a people
don't worry
there are lots of artists creating
digital art and conceptualizing brand
new art forms that you can afford
i direct media entrepreneurship and
innovation at the creative media
industries institute at georgia state
university
and our students are building the
metaverse as i speak
we imagine a future where the students
and all digital artists are able to
continue building new visions and new
worlds
basically a better internet
and can make a living while doing so the
revolutionary instrument that allowed
for a digital file to be sold as a
unique artwork
for 69 million dollars
is the same tool that will allow our
students to make livings as freelance
creators
there is a paradigm shift happening that
is turning the world of content creation
and its financial rewards on its head
gone are the days of the internet being
a giant copying machine of
intermediaries taking a larger cut than
the creators
and of artists not receiving royalties
this new automated tool that allows for
guaranteed proof of origination and
ownership of music videos images
and even text
is called an nft
non-fungible token
the nft is allowing everyone to own
their own data
starting with art
and there is a hope that it will
revolutionize how value is created
online and how digital labor is
monetized
so the eternal question what is an nft
simply put
it is a permanent tracking device that
proves ownership of a digital file
somewhat similar to the way that you can
ship a pet to identify it as yours if it
runs away an nft is a cryptographic
token connected to a digital asset to
preserve ownership
rights in the metaverse
non-fungible means not exchangeable most
things in the real world are
non-fungible
because most physical objects are unique
and can't be traded one-for-one
there is no painting pet or person that
is exactly equivalent to another
money on the other hand is one of the
few items that is fungible
meaning one dollar is equivalent to
another dollar
and when bitcoin is equivalent to
another bitcoin
the underlying decentralized technology
that enabled digital currencies such as
bitcoin
is blockchain
blockchain prevents digital money from
being duplicated or hacked and it
removes
the need for a centralized authority
such as a bank
to validate transactions and like
bitcoin the record of ownership of an
nft
is kept in a public database on the
internet that is maintained by millions
of computers that keep track via
consensus
of all content origination and
transactions
at the blockchain lab at georgia state
university we study how to monetize
creative labor using blockchains and
other decentralized ledger technologies
i believe that this technology in the
form of nfts has the potential to
humanize the internet
and to create an equitable foundation
for its next phase
the metaverse this decentralized
business model
gives financial power back to the
creators and reduces the power of the
broker the middleman and even social
media platforms
amy raider is a fine artist in atlanta
who shows in traditional galleries
she created her first nft so that she
could expand to an online audience
and to add a new revenue stream to
increase her income
here's a greg mike mural
if you're from atlanta you have probably
seen some of his work on walls and
buildings
street art is not permanent so how will
an important cultural icon like greg
mike utilize this new creative economy
he is using the unique qualities of nfts
to innovate and to collaborate with
other artists and musicians and connect
with fans on the internet this way his
work will live on and he can take the
proceeds from the sales and resales and
continue creating his art
musicians can also capture their true
value using nfts
atlanta music producer dallas austin
is allowing fans to collect memorabilia
of his great moments in music history
similar to the way that nba top shots is
allowing basketball fans to collect
historical replays as nfts
in the metaverse humans are represented
as avatars
an eight-year-old probably knows but did
you know that you can buy clothes for
your avatar
this is katie james she is leading the
way in digital fashion that can only be
worn in the virtual world
today gucci sells sneakers that only
exist in the virtual world and you can
never wear them
but your avatar can alternatively you
can use augmented reality to overlay
virtual sneakers onto your real life
feet
and because of nfts anyone not just
well-known companies like gucci
can create digital fashion to be bought
sold and worn
in games
online
platforms and even in avatar fashion
shows
take the pioneer 18 year old ferocious
who was way ahead of gucci with his
crypto art and digital sneakers the use
of augmented and virtual reality fashion
is becoming mainstream but because nfts
as art and collectibles are so new
the predictions
are too volatile for anyone to make
but it is a sign that heavy hitters like
mark cuban and snoop dogg
are investing heavily
this is a new frontier for artists and
their fans and just like in the real
world
an artist can sell a one-of-a-kind piece
make limited editions to control for
scarcity
show and art show in art galleries and
marketplaces
but with nfts
you can also sell directly to your buyer
without an intermediary
collect royalties on all future resales
expand your audience to the entire
internet
show in virtual galleries and virtual
worlds
and sell 3d objects and clothes to
virtual humans
okay so how does this work and how do
you get involved as an artist
your artwork is a digital file
to protect this file and capture the
value of your labor in perpetuity
you go to a digital goods marketplace
and mint it
meaning you register your work
as a token for a fee
on the blockchain
it will contain a signature
timestamp and any rules around its
resale
once you have minted your work and you
want to sell it
you connect with your community and let
them know that your nft has dropped
meaning it is for sale
it is important to note
that all the same rules
that make for good art and good business
apply in the virtual world
a strong connection
to your followers
an authentic or compelling story
and consistent output and work ethic
so who will buy your art or how do you
get involved as a collector
buyers go to the same marketplaces that
artists use
there you look for art that you
appreciate and artists you want a direct
connection with
some people invest because the artwork
resonates with them
or they recognize great talent
or they see a potential for that artist
to play a significant part in history
once purchased
directly from the artist
you store your nfts in your digital
wallet
from there
you can show on screens in online
marketplaces or in galleries such as
rare rooms a blockchain innovation by
atlanta's gig labs and with nfts a buyer
knows their art is fair trade
transactions are transparent and the
ecosystem is equitable
the metaverse is a place where we will
spend more and more of our lives who
builds it who owns it and how it is
built will determine
what this world becomes but just like
the real world
the metaverse is very complex and there
are many problems yet to be solved
and that is where you come in
you are the future a digital citizen
whose responsibility it is to be a good
steward to the metaverse making sure
that it is diverse
equitable accessible
and sustainable
this is just the beginning of the
decentralized movement
nfts will revolutionize most online
industries
but it is starting with the creative
economy
while nothing in this talk is financial
advice
it is definitely educational
encouragement
and why not start learning through art
jump in
we need you
i would like to thank the artist who
provided the art for the art for this
talk
all of which are embedded in the
blockchain
as nfts
non-fungible tokens